5200 block of east sahara which is a
trailer park in the area of sahara and
sloan
the details that i'm sharing right now
are very preliminary but around 4 30
this afternoon clark county fire
responded to the trailer directly behind
me on report of a full structure fire
when they responded they found the body
of what we believe to well a human body
was found inside the back trailer and we
also
have recovered three
bodies of a believed to be dogs that are
the family pets
at this point what we have learned is
that there was this morning at around
seven o'clock there was a domestic
disturbance that took place at the
trailer patrol officers responded and
settled that domestic disturbance at
scene due to the fact it was determined
to be a property dispute
this afternoon several hours after that
is when the structure fire took place
i'm being very vague on some of the
details that were shared with me through
speaking with the arson investigators
but after speaking with them in the
conversation that we had
we have now taken over as far as a death
investigation working with clark county
fire as we do on most fire deaths
so again we are still trying to
determine what led up to the fire it's
going to be several hours before we're
able to process the crime scene and have
more information for you
what we do know is at this point there's
one person who is still outstanding who
we believe was involved in the earlier
domestic disturbance so again i'll keep
it vague i'll answer a couple questions
if you have them but i don't know how
much more i can get into
was the body be covered inside the
trailer or outside the body is inside
the trailer and again we believe we know
it's an uh
a human we believe it's going to be a
female but again that's still early on
and we can't confirm that at this point
who lived in the trailer
there's several people that lived in the
trailer that's what we're still in the
process of trying to determine the
actual residents that lived in the
trailer
but we do know from the prior call we're
able to determine that there were
several people we've identified those
people but there's still one person who
is outstanding who was here this morning
if the human died in the fire or prior
to the fire again i don't know that
right now and it's it's very uh hard to
process this crime scene due to the fact
that clark county fire uh tried used a
lot of water and resources to put out
the fire trying to save the structure so
again there's a lot of debris and water
inside the trailer so it's going to make
it very difficult is it believe the
person that died was involved in that
at this point we believe the person that
is
tentatively believed to be deceased
inside there is involved in the earlier
domestic but again it's still very early
on in this investigation
right now we are trying to locate a male
who we know was at the house this
morning but again it's still
early on we're still working through
that and as the night goes on we have a
little bit more details i'll have more
answers to that
i'm not getting anything more specific
on that
you've got a witness uh placing him back
here eight hours later at four o'clock 4
30 at a time i'm being intentionally
vague on some of those details
what would be your message to um uh
neighbors in the area that are kind of
shaken up by this
you know i
the neighbors did exactly what we would
ask them to do if there was a fire they
called 9-1-1 fire department responded
in an effort to save anyone's lives who
were inside the trailer i urge anybody
who has any information to reach out to
crime stoppers that information is
completely anonymous or you can also
reach out to homicide at lvmpd all right
thank you guys i appreciate it